[Música]
bueno para comenzar quisiera que piensen
en algún adjetivo despectivo de cómo
llamarían a alguien cobarde alguien
debido a que tramposo porque no hay un
poco hombre les voy a dar unos cuantos
segundos
temas que seguro que algunas de las
palabras que se les vino a la cabeza son
temas que seguro que alguno o algunos de
ustedes pensaron de ser gay pero bardem
es la respuesta para más adelante pero
sin hacer trampa pero comenzamos desde
estas respuestas no pensemos y que es
bueno según la grandiosa rai
se entiende como alguien como un
hombre afeminado
medroso falta de coraje
dicho de alguien homosexual en este caso
pero marika
han tenido que significa que se
debería considerar un insulto que ser
realmente
bueno soy en este caso
entendiendo como alguien gay vendría a
ser parte de las diversidades sexuales
por ende comprendería la parte
sentimental la parte afectiva
la parte espiritual la parte
sexual en este caso de un hombre con
otro hombre adentro de las diversidades
sexuales pues existen otras diversidades
sexuales como por ejemplo las personas
heterosexuales las personas bisexuales
transexuales asexuales entre otros y ya
que estamos hablando de diversidad pues
igual hay que hablar de lo que es la
expresión y la identidad de género que
es más o menos vendría a ser como nos
identificamos y como nos expresamos de
acuerdo a lo que se vive aquí adentro
esto puede coincidir o no con el sexo
con el que nacemos ahí estaríamos
hablando de personas transexuales
travestis transgéneros y género no
binarias entre otras y pues aquí hay que
recalcar algo la orientación sexual y la
identidad y expresión de género son
independientes
qué pasa cuando tú eres ese algo no
porque para muchas personas es algo
despectivo porque pasa cuando tú eres de
hacer algo
para continuar déjenme contarles una
historia
había una vez un muchachito que vivía en
el carmen en la calle 4 él creció viendo
todo tipo de programas así como tareas
los simpsons jackass y me gustaba mucho
la música a todo tipo de música él
escuchaba de este club y hasta metal y
pues también jugaban bastante con los
videojuegos conjunto con su hermana
gabriela con videojuegos como cracks
como taken pues a él le llamaban de
diferentes maneras le llevaban loco les
llamaban lado le llamaban rebelde y
bueno es que también hacía algunas cosas
tontas como por ejemplo tomar cosas
asquerosas mostrar el trasero en público
o simplemente a veces le llamaban así
poder ser quien él era
pero bueno el muchacho se sentía lleno
de ilusiones llenos de sueños
pero también al igual que muchos y
muchas de ustedes se sintieron en algún
momento se sentía perdido
y muy confundido
una de las primeras pasiones que este
flacucho hecho alma lo encontraría es la
lucha libre y esto gracias a que su mamá
francia y su hermana pues le hicieran
ver lo que era pues la wc www v y alguna
vez la distinta 'furia de titanes' está
en la televisión nacional y pues poco a
poco se fue inspirando en estos
luchadores y en estas luchadoras en sus
atuendos y en lo que iban contando
dentro del ring y un día se puso a
pensar qué pasaría así es que yo
paso de ser fanático a ser luchador
y pues esta vida de lucha libre es algo
más hermético no es como que uno va a un
gimnasio en cuenta clases de zumba de
cuatro a cinco clases de lucha libre de
cinco a seis no es no conocía a alguien
dentro de la lucha libre a diferencia de
mucha gente que está en este negocio
pero para su buena suerte allá por el
2007 hubiera un evento de lucha libre
hay cerca de donde vivía en el puente
minas a hay todo el primer contacto cara
a cara con la lucha libre paralelamente
ese mismo año
se producía un ataque con bomba molotov
en el desfile del orgullo lgtb
aquí en la ciudad de la paz bolivia como
constante del observatorio por los
derechos lgtb de bolivia
y aquí estamos hablando de diversidades
el muchacho se sentía diferente
pero no en una manera
pensaría se sentía diferente sino de
manera más profunda
el sentía lo que le habían dicho que
debía sentir por las chicas pero yo lo
sentía por los chicos y esto lo llenaba
de miedo
porque él entendía lo violento lo
agresivo
y lo discriminador y acosador que puede
llegar a ser el entorno tampoco el
conocí a muchas personas de las
diversidades más que los chicos que se
ligaba en secreto pues sí que se sentían
igual de perdidos y llenos de miedo que
era
bueno después de unos cuantos meses de
entrenamiento ser el más flaco del grupo
aún están en colegio y pues
contra todo pronóstico y estaba por
debutar en la lucha libre donde darían a
entender el duro derecho de piso que
implica ser un luchador de lucha libre
está
listo para subir al ring con su ropa
diaria una máscara de rey mysterio que
el corto
y un millón de mentiras en casa para que
no se enterarán que él era un luchador
de lucha libre
y su viaje en conocer el pensamiento
el de no orinar se de miedo
cuando ya es lento de esa lucha sobre
decir que fue un desastre no pudo hacer
las llaves que él quiso salió todo muy
mal
hasta el día de hoy viendo esta lucha
todavía me recuerda muchas muchas cosas
cuando recuerdo esa historia
pero bueno
pasaba algo fuera de todo eso
porque no es serían estas las cosas que
ese muchacho
recordaría
pasó algo en esa lucha que lo marcaría
que la que el público conformada en su
mayoría por familias empezaron a gritar
algo al réferi y al luchador malo saben
que empezaron a gritar
porque luchador rudo y el réferi youtube
gran combates eran débiles eran
incapaces de ganar por sí mismos
pero todo esto él sabía que no estaba
dirigido ahí pero era difícil no tomarlo
así le llamaba le llenaba de ansiedad y
de miedo
cuándo
él empezó a crecer sentía que le faltaba
ese referente pues en las producciones
internacionales es más común ver
representaciones de las diversidades
pero estas representaciones muchas veces
pueden ser muy humanas o pueden ser
otras veces muy estereotipadas pero lo
que él sentía que le faltaba era que en
ese contexto alguien que estuviera en su
situación similar por eso es que en las
representaciones de las diversidades que
son muy pocas pero en muchas de estas
pocas representaciones vienen cargadas
de pues prejuicio de burla y de sátira
entonces esto le dice afirmaba ese tipo
de sentimientos estabas haciendo crecer
con una especie de indefensión aprendida
y con serios problemas de autoestima
entonces el sentido que le faltaba a
alguien que le dijera esta vez está bien
ser como tú eres está bien es sentirse
así y está bien que no estás luchando
así y vas a salir de esto porque igual
no salir y eso que le faltaba
y bueno y entiendo que en las
diversidades para mucha gente es algo
despectivo y algo que debe ser
invisibilizado esta invisibilización
viene acompañada de agresiones y a veces
estas agresiones
pueden comenzar con uno menos lo esperan
como el muchacho que los re confirmaría
cuando estaba en colegio recibiera su
primera amenaza de muerte donde le
dirían textualmente te vamos a matar por
no sería la última en la primera
agresión que recibiera
y qué es lo que causa ese tipo de
agresiones
este tipo de agresiones hacen que noten
que las personas no pueden tener una
vida plena hacen que se pierdan ciertas
etapas de su vida como por ejemplo la
adolescencia momentos tan tan tan
tenemos sentado como salir con tu novio
tu novia de la mano es algo impensable
para muchas personas en ciertos
contextos
si bien en bolivia la homosexualidad no
está criminalizada ni penalizada como
pasa en muchos otros países no garantiza
eso que nuestros derechos vayan a ser
respetados si bien recientemente se dio
la primera unión libre en el país
reconocido en el país esto no quiere
decir que vayamos a tener una calidad de
vida porque todavía sigue habiendo esas
agresiones no podemos hablar de cifras
ciento por ciento exactas cuando no
sabemos dónde denunciar ni cómo hacerlo
por temor a que nos repiten
o por temor a que no se tome en serio
y es que a base de esos prejuicios se
están cerrando puertas de estudios de
trabajo se está imposibilitando a las
personas a que vivan su vida
recuerden esa respuesta que dieron en un
comienzo salgan la de vuelta
ahora analicemos las de donde nace de
esa falta de empatía
de en dónde nace ese prejuicio a veces
así está tan normalizado este tipo de
agresiones que ni pensamos que es algo
malo
decía así son las cosas deberíamos los
signos pues lo que muchas personas dicen
pero esa agresión que parece chiste va
escalando de agresión verbal agresión
física psicológica
todo esto desembocando en crímenes de
odio o sea asesinatos
y por qué no pasa en las noticias
nacionales que eran que no está pasando
acá en bolivia o por qué no que no está
pasando en otros países
es algo cotidiano de día a día y solo
nos damos cuenta hasta que le toca a
alguien que conocemos según la fundación
todo mejora las personas de la población
lgtb
tenemos 4 veces más chances de cometer
suicidio
esto quiere decir que tenemos más
chances de sufrir también de
enfermedades enfermedades mentales
todo esto por las agresiones que vamos
sufriendo
y es una realidad que muchas personas de
las diversidades viven y vivieron
así con el muchacho que lo vivió y lo
vio
pero no todo era malo
también conocido a las personas
correctas en los momentos correctos y
estas personas que ya no sabían del
impacto que tenían en su vida pero poco
a poco le hicieron entender y le
hicieron sentir querido porque en él era
la aceptaron y eso ya cosas tan básicas
que nos olvidamos en el momento que
conocemos a alguien diferente entre
comillas que sale de nuestro paradigma
hicieran que fue el muchacho
vivió mil y un cosas tanto dentro como
fuera de zinc tuvo muchos aciertos
muchos desaciertos
pero eso se los contaré otro día en otro
momento en otro proyecto pero lo que sí
les puedo contar es que tras muchas
derrotas muchas victorias ella pensaba
que era momento de colgar las botas que
en el momento de salirse de la lucha
libre pero el día y abrazado el orgullo
de años atrás y como dice ese hashtag
que adoro decidió sacar la furia y
sé que un día
que sus obras más caras
y decidió portar la bandera del orgullo
dentro de esos combates y estaba crash
quien según muchas personas en hacer el
primer luchador abiertamente a kate de
bolivia
y pueden aunque nos parezca sorprendente
el muchacho de la historia de soy yo
y pues fue la toda lucha libre también
quería hacer otras cosas ese luchador de
las periferias de las villas donde se
desarrollan los shows de la lucha libre
quería encontrarse en otros aspectos
trágico en el tiempo me volvió un
diseñador gráfico un ilustrador un
fotógrafo un activista un artista visual
un amigo un novio un ex novio un hijo un
hermano
me volví todas las cosas que me dijeron
que yo no podría ser como
pero instala
queremos que todas las personas vienen y
libertad hasta que por un segundo nos
ponemos en sus zapatos
nos ponen límites sin siquiera
conocernos nos enseñan que es más fácil
lastimar que querer que es más fácil
pues juzgar que aceptar quizás
en un sistema así no está mal se rebelde
porque nos dicen que somos débiles
cuando todo en dentro de nosotros grita
fuerza y grita valor no hay mayor acto
de rebeldía que buscar la felicidad y no
hay mayor acto de referencia que
encontrarla
pues quizás no en mis días en la lucha
libre estén contados quién sabe quizás
no voy a tener esos momentos como
luchador esos momentos resolverían
quizás no vayan a llegar
pero quizás este sea el momento porque
hice lo que un
[Música]
le dijeron que no podría ser y lo logré
es lo que mi vida lo que yo quería
y ese va a ser mi mayor luego como
luchador
pero también como yo aprendí una
cosa tu puede ser feliz que un
puede luchar por sus sueños tú
puedes admirado por los niños
que un tiene ese derecho
todos tenemos el derecho a la felicidad
porque no es el privilegio de unos pocos